okay thank you we are still learning new
details in a deadly bush
bus crash rather that happened friday
afternoon in northwestern arizona
we're told the bus was in route to the
grand canyon west from las vegas
48 people were on board 8 news now
reporter madison kimbrough has more on
this developing story tonight
sasha the tour bus was headed to grand
canyon west when all of a sudden the bus
crashed by rolling over and landing on
its side
this happening on mild post 5 on diamond
bar road
as of now we can confirm that one person
was found dead on scene
according to terry williams the
communications and marketing director
of kingman regional medical center they
saw a total of 45 patients
of those patients three were considered
serious but are now stable 40 were
treated for minor injuries
but then released and two were treated
and then transferred to a local
las vegas hospital the cause of the
crash has not been announced yet
although a fire official who responded
to the scene on friday
said that speed did appear to be a
factor this investigation is still
ongoing but we expect to learn more
information
monday afternoon according to the mohave
county sheriff's office
reporting in the newsroom madison
kimbrough 8 news now